in the lobby of Ramsey solutions mark
and Jessica are with us hey guys how are
ya good
welcome welcome where're you from
Fishers Indiana welcome to Nashville and
here to do it that free scream yes they
are how much of you guys paid off twenty
eight thousand five hundred and twenty
$5.34 I love it and how long did that
take twelve months exactly to the day oh
man oh just like that and range of
income during that time from 1:10 down
to about eighty now okay so tell me your
story what happened twelve months ago we
were sick of working our behinds off
I'll way to be using our credit card for
gas at the end of the month mm-hmm and
we have to build boys mm-hmm here with
this that really changed our lives so we
had to reset our priorities in life they
were born twelve months ago we have a
three year old and a ten month old oh
yeah and right before we started a
debt-free scream we had our the
debt-free process we had a miscarriage
and we had to make financial plans to
pay for that every month and that's what
got me to where I didn't want to be
reminded of that every month I wanted to
pay it and be done with it and so that's
what really got me started yeah what a
hooky debt yeah yeah so that that caused
you to decide to get after this and then
how did you connect up with us actually
I've been I'm an insurance adjuster and
I'm a mobile so I ride around on my my
Ford Transit yeah got you on the radio
station out of Bloomington Indiana
mm-hmm and got really motivated then I
want my coworkers Chris sarella and one
my old buddies from the Marine Corps
Tim turret mm-hmm I really got me God
has motivated to start doing this and
mm-hmm
so Jessica you're like I don't wanna
make this pain anymore Mark comes home
he's been listen this weird guy on the
radio how did that conversation go down
well he actually he also listens to you
when he's getting ready in the morning
the Lord so we all hear our
three-year-old talks about you and so he
said I think we need to look into this
so we kind of had been starting the debt
snowball looking at things and then he
said let's get online and let's get the
program and we actually it worked out
best for us to do
home our church had just finished it so
we started doing it at home and that was
kind of date night after the boys went
to bed okay you got the home study FPU
natural Peace University home study okay
very cool well congratulations Eugene
yeah very good very good so on yeah you
had some serious motivation here it was
like you were a little sick and tired of
being sick and tired we need to get rid
of this constant monthly reminder yeah
and and then just just got pounded on
your from the radio as you're riding
around and there we go yeah from about
three or four different directions yeah
yeah pretty cool and so what what kind
of debt was the twenty nine thousand we
had credit cards the miscarriage debt
card debt we had debt to a general
contractor student loans 401k loan and
big dennis bill dont normal yeah you so
everybody yeah now this just cut you got
to feel like you took a shower like this
is gotta feel clean yeah it's
unbelievable Wow very neat and you did
this really really fast yeah I mean
twelve months is good that's that's
excellent so what do you tell people the
keys to getting out of debt are you des
were very successful discipline and my
biggest thing was learning what the
definition of a need route truly was
because the world's is a little
different than what we've you know
really need to live so that was the
biggest thing and what mine was uh you
learn how to put your pride away to have
some other guy telling you how to handle
your money so the the the thing you got
sick and tired of being sick and tired I
guess there was a little bit of just I'm
over this mm-hmm down in there wasn't
there and that gives you the discipline
doesn't it yeah discipline doesn't just
lied on your shoulder like a butterfly I
mean you got to just decide there's I'm
so tired of this that I'm not gonna do
that
yeah I mean I don't do this need one
thing anymore I'm just don't need
anything we're not doing nothing I'm
getting out of debt yeah and you got to
get this thing going didn't you yeah we
actually dipped into our emergency fund
when we were here yeah
our minivan broke down and sober at the
shop across the interstate yes oh my
gosh so we're about eight hundred
dollars short arm renze fund but we
wouldn't be able to pay for it if we
didn't have your program yeah that was a
bad shape
well congratulations you guys I'm very
proud of you you're heroes now the kids
ages or in names or what Isaac it's
three mm-hmm
let's get them into the picture buddy
Isaac is three and what else
Ezekiel Zeke dragon Zeke all right bring
in big Zeke in he's a big boy yeah all
right very cool got that head you guys
are great what a great family you've
changed your family tree you guys yeah
you're heroes you got to feel good about
yourself good
you should we're proud of you very good
stuff all right mark and Jessica Isaac
and Zeke from Indianapolis $29,000 paid
off in 12 months making 110 down to 80
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream
yeah
Wow very very very well done I love it
congratulations you guys absolutely
amazing so proud of it hey guys thanks
for watching if you enjoyed this video
click the subscribe button to get the
latest content and check out these other
great clips from the show and so you
have to break the cycle you have to flip
this thing on its head and make it
behave you've got to get so fired up and
wired up that you're broke friends think
you've lost your mind